a lot of insults being thrown around
people are liars people are blackmailing
the Greek government or that perhaps
your guys just don't know what they're
doing no and I think part of why there
is this confusion is because of the
reporting that we have in the media so
as you saw before the question that we
are poisoned for the referendum is not
no or yes in relation to staying or not
in the urine the you don't know but
let's clarify that the question
differential even if they are the
solution is very very clear the question
is do you accept the bailout do you
accept the proposal of the institutions
or not it has nothing to do with the Udo
or the euros it does because it has
implications and the yes your government
is not being honest I mean when when
when this time my government has been
negotiating table and that's where we
still I understand that but we're making
you know we talked to a lot of people
not just from the Greek government and
the general view is that if the terms of
this deal if an agreement is not reached
Greece's position in the euro is
untenable and yet your Prime Minister
goes on the television and says this is
not about no not except he's misleading
and I would not accept that because what
effectively you are saying is that there
is no other way in the eurozone then
austerity and I really want to challenge
that what we are saying is that we want
better conditions and growth and making
the dead which is a big understand
something about is your possession where
should I have ease about if there's a
lot a mature way of going about politics
I know you'd like to have a different
political world but the reality is
Greece has entered into this has any I'm
making yeah all did except he made
that's the point you're not making you
have made no Reese has entered into
these arrangements good mixing iron man
it has a huge victory now which has been
nourished by one-third I feel very sorry
for you but the final matter is when I
wouldn't feel sorry for us because these
are straight but I'll be no but we think
that you
that's what the position is the position
is effectively the Greek government is
saying give us the money for give us the
money that we have borrowed and I'm just
saying unfortunately in relations
between governments that's not our work
can I reply to that the money that we
have boarded have to do with a banking
system in Europe this money that we have
been boring they have not gone to the
Greek people or the greek state this is
only eight percent and the probiem there
is the banking system of beliefs is part
of the banking system system hang off
the US and all that and countries small
countries have been hit very hard I was
in Ireland this week the Irish take a
much higher line the ning harder line of
the English because they were hit by the
banking crisis small country smaller
even van Greece yet they've gone through
a great deal of austerity and now
they're back in a growth and they are
they say what is valuable to us is being
in the euro no I don't think that I've
been flying and these out of them mmm oh
don't worry nylander people are very
much of you you'll be like you'll be
like very [ __ ] is saying what he says in
private is different what he says on the
wrist board I mean things you can't miss
you know what is happening there was
assessing or not I tiny different
angular Merkel's view to simply
reinterpret the world no I wish you'd
like it is everything the world as we
have said we want the different Europe
and Democratic you don't anyways these
are very dark basis is this is the
question this is the for Union and the
European Union and the eurozone what we
are facing with is a black male which is
trying to employment you poor ability to
repay the European Union that when we
have a common currency we are trying to
manage the situation so there is no
crisis and visas for the common good of
the eurozone this is why we've asked
before the next time you question this
is right today we are Greece well
implemented reforms at the same level of
space and we go normal and much bigger
reforms as we are trying to fight
corruption tax evasion on the higher
levels but what these proposals were
about is he
the middle and lower incomes and this is
what we don't want I agree with you
there is 134 it has to be reformed but
it has to be reformed in a way that
those is quite appropriate apologize
grease can reform itself but once it
goes into a deal with other countries
with the other members of the eurozone
we had with the International Monetary
Fund it's the same here we had this in
the 1970s you are not because you borrow
money from someone else you are not in
full control of shaping your world men
tonight Abigail we are not asking for a
favor what we are asking but usually
saying these are the terms of the loan
we accepted there at the time that that
loan was accepted that was accepted by
the Greek government and now a new Greek
government that says those rules don't
apply let me respondes going the
programs that they have been imposed on
Greece they created a huge humanitarian
crisis they devastated the cry to the
country and on top of that they
increased the debt for one third have
you read the newspapers today these are
from the papers of the institutions they
say that until 2030 even if there is
except these proposals that will not be
sustainable so these proposals that they
have destroyed the country they have to
stop let me just put one final thing to
you when the Tsaritsa government took
over growth was small but Greece was
back in growth it's not in great
impression now why is now island which
has implemented austerity measures is
now back in growth you know these are
not original point pass this government
doesn't know what it's doing no I think
the government knows very well what it's
doing and this referendum is about
democracy and putting it back to the
Greek people will have to decide let's
see if they waitin where we thank you